Francia celebra la clasificación de su
selección a la final del mundial de
fútbol título que disputará Argentina
este domingo el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron recibió críticas por su
presencia en Qatar para la semifinal
conectaremos con nuestra enviada
especial adoja
en Bruselas los líderes de la Unión
Europea se reúnen con el escándalo del
qatargate y la situación económica
derivada de la alta inflación y de la
crisis energética generada por la guerra
en Ucrania como trasfondo conectaremos
con la capital Europea
el 18 de diciembre se conmemora el Día
Internacional del migrante y en France
24 hemos preparado una serie de
reportajes especiales para conmemorarlo
hoy hablamos de las rutas clandestinas
en el mar Mediterráneo este 2022
2400 personas han muerto intentando
llegar a Europa por este camino
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez +
deu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
deportiva porque hay alegría en Francia
que venció 2-0 a Marruecos en las
semifinal de Qatar 2022 y ahora se
prepara para enfrentar a Argentina en la
gran final del domingo mientras la
afición francesa celebró la victoria
hasta altas horas de la noche el mundo
árabe se llenó de orgullo por la proeza
de los marroquíes en esta copa mundo
la esperanza de una tercera estrella
hizo explotar en Euforia a las calles de
Francia con una victoria de 2 a 0 contra
la sorpresa del torneo Marruecos
apuntan a lo que sería un hito
convertirse en la primera selección en
más de 60 años en levantar Dos copas del
mundo consecutivas
es enorme y dos veces seguidas eso no
pasa vivíe de champs se convertirá en
leyenda incluso más de la que ya es
sería algo muy loco muy loco
un partido cargado no solo por la
rivalidad sino también por el pasado
colonial las nuevas generaciones fruto
de la inmigración no se quedan ahora sin
motivos para seguir la fiesta todos
somos franceses después de todo
Marruecos jugó genial hicieron historia
para el fútbol africano en la Copa del
Mundo estamos felices a pesar de la
derrota y ahora continuaremos celebrando
porque tenemos ambas nacionalidades
Marruecos se convirtió en el primer
equipo árabe en llegar a cuartos de
final y el primer equipo africano en
disputar una semi de un mundial una
derrota agridulce pero que dejó al mundo
árabe con la frente en alto
los marroquíes jugaron un gran partido y
es suficiente que hayan estado entre los
cuatro mejores ningún país árabe o
africano había llegado antes a este
nivel no sé qué decir pero ellos son
héroes Argentina también dos veces
campeona del mundo sueña a la par de
Francia con una tercera estrella en la
camiseta y con llevar el título del
mundo a América del Sur será un duelo de
astros que el domingo se convertirá en
el centro del universo fútbol
continuamos con información del mundial
pero vamos ahora a Qatar con nuestra
enviada especial Natalia Ruiz Natalia
Buenos días Cuál es el ambiente tras la
victoria de Francia
muy buenos días Pues todavía celebración
y de hecho ya hemos visto aquí por estas
calles en la zona donde nos encontramos
aquí en doja en hoteles ya están
poniendo banderas grandísimas tanto de
Francia como de Argentina muchísimas
celebración celebración también que tuvo
el presidente Manuel presente en ese
partido en la noche de ayer en el
estadio celebró con los jugadores de
Francia quienes abrazó también pudo
hablar con jugadores de Marruecos el
presidente lo han criticado mucho por
estar aquí pero él les dijo ya en Rusia
yo había hecho Exactamente lo mismo
había venido a apoyar al equipo La idea
es de compartir y de disfrutar este
momento dijo que esta copa del mundo no
tenía mayores problemas de organización
Qatar había ahí anotado pues muy buenos
puntos tampoco problemas de seguridad y
que todos esos temas otros que quedan
por resolver haciendo pues una Clara
alusión a los temas en cuanto a derecho
laboral en cuanto a derechos humanos
pues esas son cosas que pueden irse
hablando poco a poco y que finalmente el
fútbol puede ser ese tema ese eso
Federal a los países cuando no logran
finalmente hablarse políticamente En
todo caso él de esta manera pues ha
tratado de despejar todas las críticas
que se le han hecho de viajar en este
momento aquí sobre todo por parte de la
izquierda francesa Natalia Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información nosotros
cambiamos de tema vamos a Bruselas donde
los líderes de la Unión Europea se
reúnen este jueves con dos grandes
frentes abiertos por un lado la
situación económica derivada de la
inflación y de la crisis energética y
por otro lado la gestión del llamado
catergate el caso recordemos de
corrupción que vincula altos
funcionarios europeos con el cobro de
sobornos a por parte de Qatar conectamos
ahora con nuestra corresponsal en la
capital europea Esther Herrera Esther
Buenos días Cuál es el ambiente en
Bruselas casi una semana después de que
estallara este escándalo el catergate y
tras la destitución de la vicepresidenta
de la eurocámara Eva kylip qué otras
medidas esperan
Buenos días las instituciones europeas
siguen en shotas este supuesto caso de
corrupción hoy precisamente los
orientados desde estrasburgo han votado
una resolución con 541 votos a favor en
que han pedido más medidas y más
transparencia para evitar casos
parecidos y han pedido que se paralice
toda legislación que tenga que ver con
Qatar al respecto la presidenta de la
eurocámara Roberta mechola que está aquí
hoy en Bruselas ha anunciado un gran
paquete de medidas para reformar desde
dentro de la institución Como por
ejemplo proteger a los informadores en
caso de que desmpleguen casos de
corrupción y también se prohibirá los
grupos no oficiales de amistad entre
eurodiputados y países para evitar por
ejemplo sobornos además también se
prohibirá y se vigilará aún más grupos
de presión que intenten influir en la
legislación europea todo esto se produce
con más informaciones que se están
produciendo ayer Francesco georghi y la
pareja de la ex vicepresidenta Eva
declaración aceptó que participó en esta
supuesta trama de sobornos y además ha
apuntado a más eurodiputados al respecto
de todas maneras Eva kylin no pudo
declarar debido a una huelga de
funcionarios en la prisión en la que se
encuentra por lo tanto tendrá que
declarar la semana que viene Esther y
otro de los grandes temas de esta Cumbre
no es como enfrentar la situación
económica y particularmente como
competir con la ley de reducción de la
inflación impulsada por Estados Unidos
haya consenso entre los 27 para llevar a
cabo una respuesta conjunta
Bueno lo cierto es que es una cuestión
que preocupa mucho a los líderes
europeos de hecho el presidente francés
Manuel macron ha dicho que por ejemplo
la propuesta de la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula fonder Legend de
crear un fondo soberano un fondo para
hacer frente a esta ley de reducción de
la inflación va en el buen camino Aunque
otros países como por ejemplo Países
Bajos dice que aún tienen que analizarla
y que quizás se podría utilizar con
recursos ya existentes en todo caso sí
que la gran mayoría de países cree que
hay que tener una respuesta firme y
concreta ante una ley que consideran que
puede ser que puede damnificar a la
Unión Europea Esther Muchísimas gracias
por su reporte
y el 18 de diciembre es el día del
migrante y en France 24 lo conmemoramos
toda la semana con una serie de
reportajes especiales en el siguiente
informe revisamos lo que ocurre en el
mar Mediterráneo donde solo en el año
2022 murieron más de 2.400 personas
provenientes en su mayoría de África y
de oriente medio el mar es la principal
ruta migratoria hacia Europa y también
la más peligrosa
votes como estos navegan por el mar
Mediterráneo a bordo migrantes que
buscan mejores oportunidades en Europa y
el escenario la ruta más letal para el
tránsito desde 2014 más de 25.000
migrantes desaparecieron en la travesía
y en 2022 esa cifra casi alcanza los
2000 el del Mediterráneo Central es el
trayecto por el que más se embarcan
desde las costas africanas en 2022 el
número de cruces fronterizos irregulares
detectados por frontex la guardia de
fronteras Europea
en un
49%, es decir fueron casi 94.000
personas en tránsito por el Mediterráneo
central la mayoría de migrantes que
atravesaron por esa ruta en 2022
salieron de Egipto túnez y Siria al
rescate nuevamente estuvieron las
organizaciones No gubernamentales que
enfrentaron los mismos desafíos
hacinamientos encubierta y la negativa
de los países europeos para garantizar
un puerto seguro
actualmente estamos en una posición de
enfrentamiento en aguas internacionales
de sicilia con 234 mujeres hombres y
niños a bordo entre ellos El
Sobreviviente más joven tiene tres años
y tenemos más de 40 menores no
acompañados que viajan solos
y la respuesta humanitaria sigue como un
pendiente el tema migratorio durante el
último año enfrentó a gobiernos como el
de Francia e Italia y volvió a dejar
Clara la radical posición de este último
país al tema y desde 2015 sigue en el
aire una respuesta europea conjunta
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]